I'd like to talk to you now about improving the color segmentation of your Robotic Visions worksheet.
Two of the techniques that you
can use is Gamma Correction and Chromaticity Co-ordinates.
Let's go into MATLAB now and investigate these two techniques.
Okay so for my getColor function here, it
has two inputs, the first is the Robotic Vision
worksheet image and the second is the color
channel that I'm interested in for the 2D
objects that I wish to segment.
So the output of this function is the segmented
2D objects, depending on the color channel.
So to improve my segmented output with my
getColor function, I've used two different
methods.
The first is Gamma Correction. Now gamma correction
can be applied through either using the igamma
function or you can also supply the gamma
input when you're using iread with the toolbox.
For this example, I'm just going to show you
how to use igamma. So for igamma we create
a new variable called limg for example and
we can call the igamma function and igamma
has two inputs; the first is your input image
which for us is just the Robotic Vision worksheet
and the second input variable is the particular
gamma correction you wish to apply.
For this example I'm just going to use sRGB.
Okay so this function has created another
image, with is the gamma corrected version
of my input image as you can see there.
So you guys should experiment with the different
gamma corrections you can apply and that will
be depended on the type of camera you have
used to take the Robotic Vision worksheet
image.
The second method I've used in getColor is
to create chromaticity co-ordinates. Now the
toolbox has a function called tristim2cc and this allows you to generate chromaticity co-ordinates from an input image.
So how that function works is that it returns
R and G values and then we call out tristim2cc
function and the input is simply just the
Robotic Vision Worksheet or whatever image
that you're interested in.
And for this example, instead of using my
original image, let's actually use the gamma
corrected image. Okay and then we can visualize that.
Okay, so you can see on the left hand side, we have the
R value of the chromaticity co-ordinate and on the right hand side we have the G value.
So for the R value on the
left, you can see that the red 2D objects
are quite bright. So they look much brighter
than say the, and they have a value up here
of 0.83 and their much brighter than the blue
2D objects, for example the circle here, which
only has a value of 0.14.
And then in between those two values, we have
the green 2D objects, so if we look at the
small green circle here, you can see it has
a G value of 0.25. Conversely on the right
hand side here with the G values, your green
2D objects have a value say of 0.62, your
red objects are quite dark this time, so the
large red square only has a G value of 0.09
and the in between values for this is now
the blue circles. So the blue circle has a
value of 0.21 for this top circle here.
So you can use the chromaticity co-ordinates
in your segmentation to try and identify what
color the 2D object is going to be a part
of, being either red, green or blue and you
can use both the red values and the green values to determine what color a particular object belongs to.
Okay, so those are the two methods that I
recommend that you use; gamma correction and
chromaticity co-ordinates. You don't have
to use these methods if you don't want to,
but I strongly recommend that you experiment with these two and see what sort of results that you get.